la campagne électorale s'est aussi 338
campagne dans toutes les régions
chaque semaine nous vous offrirons le
regard de l'une d'entre elles de l'océan
l'autre donc cette semaine vous amène à
rimouski qui concurrence presque
montréal au chapitre des chefs de partis
enfin presque pas besoin de se rendre
dans la métropole pour croiser un chef
de parti fédéral
le chef du parti forcé démocratie jean
françois fortin vie à mont joli et le
chef du parti rhinocéros
c'est bastille corino demeure à rimouski
ancien député bloquiste jean-françois
fortin est toujours souverainiste mais
en maintenant des candidats à
terre-neuve et en ontario
rien ne refroidi ses ardeurs for
democracy compte trois députés sortants
sans jamais avoir participé à des
élections et ils ont tous été élus sont
différentes douleurs deux parties jean
françois fortin présente au parti comme
celui des régions mieux la philosophie
qui sous-tend notre action c'est à dire
que nous voulons des gens impliqués dans
leur communauté
fait qui est écrit nos autres chefs
autre méthode
le chef du parti rhinocéros et bastille
corino a installé une affiche géante à
rimouski qui a dû être retiré presque
aussitôt parce qu'elle se trouvait sur
le terrain de la ville sans autorisation
présente 80 de candidats et proposent
des idées aussi farfelues que de
nationaliser les tim hortons et de
privatiser l'armée canadienne les deux
chefs ont un point commun ils sont
contre le projet de pipeline énergie est
pourtant sébastien corinne au hockey
pour l'installation d'un oléoduc à
d'autres fins ce qui est important c'est
que le sens du pipeline souhait du
québec vers l'alberta
ensuite on veut enlever le pétrole du
'pipeline' et on va faire couler un
fleuron de l'économie québécoise on veut
faire couler des bières de
microbrasseries les deux chefs vivre
loin des grands centres et leur priorité
est de développer les régions ça dure à
leur façon